hey everyone how's it going today we're
going to make something really delicious
and tasty we're gonna make some Lego
chocolate snacks I don't have any
directions but photography these for
Christmas and guess what we're gonna do
we're gonna make them and this this is
what I'm figure I've got these bars of
chocolate so I'm gonna melt them and
then put them in here pink blue green
purple this is not the right all I need
to investigate good colors so first
thing we're do is put the chocolate on
the stand hey you guys ready for this
treat Matt and Jenna are watching a
football game and I'm making handy
and burn the chocolate nobody told me
you could burn chocolate
reminding we're not going to have any
glue
guys I might have made some mistakes
yeah what is this yeah I don't know I
honestly am not sure what happened to it
to be honest
look how cute these are all right let's
go let's go serve them to the squad what
does it look like chocolate hmm Wow is
there Hugh's actually came out pretty
good yeah this is chocolate yeah it's
all chocolate tastes like white
chocolate hmm
they look really cool though hey
everyone try red one haze example like
the white mm-hmm yeah it's crazy it's
good a second it's like white chocolate
Wow thanks for watching guys I'll put a
link in description where you can get
these molds not sponsored
I just love Amazon photography needs
mold for business big deal this is
chocolate I did a little hair off he is
the sweetest little soul and he is also
I am extremely excited to announce that
he did win for the world dog Awards my
new puppy